[Aplausos]
[Música]
Por qué apoyamos a Ucrania en esta
guerra o dicho de otra forma porque
estamos en contra de Rusia vamos a ser
claros casi todos los medios de
comunicación en occidente incluido
vuestro medio favorito visualpolitik
damos por sentado que Putin es el malo
de la película y que esquí es el bueno
paréntesis por si alguno va a ponerlo en
los comentarios Nunca hemos dicho que
Ucrania sea el paraíso en la tierra es
más tenemos una larga serie de vídeos
donde hemos mostrado la corrupción y
todas las vergüenzas de los políticos
ucranianos incluso cuando le dimos un
premio visualpolitik 2021 abolodines de
lanski dejamos bien claro que ni
siquiera podemos poder garantizar que
este hombre no tenga algún escándalo de
corrupción a sus espaldas en cualquier
caso todos nuestros vídeos parten de la
premisa de que la invasión de Ucrania es
una auténtica barbaridad en todos los
sentidos no solo eso partimos de la base
de que tanto Europa como Estados Unidos
como en general todas las liberales del
mundo debemos unirnos para frenar a
Putin hemos hablado de sanciones
comerciales rearme en Europa y envíos de
armas a Ucrania Esa es la base de todos
nuestros análisis aquí en visualpolitik
y muchos con mucho juicio os
preguntaréis Por qué De verdad no hay
ningún argumento para defender o
entender la postura de Putin Y esa es la
realidad fuera más compleja que
simplemente una historia de buenos y de
malos
pues lo cierto Es que hay argumentos
legítimos para entender defender incluso
justificar la actuación de Putin O al
menos para criticar la actuación de la
otan y no no vamos a hablar ni de
propagandistas por rusos ni tampoco de
algún wanna vida influencer que estos
días intenta conseguir fama en internet
que los hay de todos los colores en
todos los países vamos a hablar de
analistas políticos de primer nivel que
no estarían para nada de acuerdo con
nosotros gente con un enorme prestigio
académico y político principalmente este
señor que veis aquí John mercemer tiene
una conferencia titulada porque Ucrania
es culpa de occidente que acumula ya más
de 27 millones de visitas en YouTube
Pues bien en este vídeo vamos a intentar
desmontar muchas de las principales
teorías que de un modo u otro critican
la actuación de occidente y a su manera
intentan un medio justificar la acción
de Putin como os podéis imaginar en este
vídeo nos vamos a mojar es decir que hay
mucha parte de posicionamiento editorial
Y por supuesto hay muchas cosas sobre
las que podéis debatir en los
comentarios lo único que os pedimos es
que se respetuosos Porque las preguntas
que hoy nos hacemos son Cuáles son las
principales teorías anti otan en esta
Guerra de Ucrania Por qué creemos que
son incorrectas cuales pensamos que son
los mayores mitos de la invasión de
Ucrania hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes sabéis Cómo podéis
apoyar activamente a visualpolitik para
que este proyecto siga siendo
independiente como lo es ahora pues
apoyándonos en nuestra comunidad de
patreon además si nos apoyáis en patrón
tendréis acceso a merchandising
exclusivo como esta camiseta que veis
aquí que no está a la venta en ningún
sitio y que solo puede conseguirse a
través de nuestra comunidad en patreon
también podréis conseguir cosas como
esta gorra que podéis ver aquí con el
logo bordado de visualpolitik Y por
supuesto tendréis acceso a nuestra
newsletter semanal las claves de la
semana además de contenido exclusivos
solo para patreons os dejo todos los
enlaces en la descripción y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
idealismo versus real politic
seguro que muchos habéis visto ya la
charla de John merce Mercy No lo habéis
visto os dejamos el enlace en la
descripción lo primero que tenemos que
entender es que este hombre representa
una ideología muy concreta en las
relaciones internacionales es uno de los
principales representantes del llamado
realismo político y diréis Pero qué
defienden los llamados realistas
Pues según su teoría El mundo es una
anarquía donde cada estado se rige por
sus propios intereses A diferencia de
los liberales los realistas creen que es
casi imposible lograr cooperación entre
Estados basándose en principios éticos
es decir que las relaciones
internacionales se fundamentan en un
juego de suma cero donde unos ganan y
otros pierden lógicamente en semejante
anarquía prima la ley del más fuerte
Pues bien bajo este prisma Rusia está
simplemente respondiendo a la expansión
de la otan que supone una amenaza
existencial contra su seguridad atentos
a este mapa
la pregunta que habría que plantearse es
de verdad se puede hablar de la
expansión de la otan pues lo cierto Es
que no
[Aplausos]
hay una diferencia muy grande entre
expandir una organización es decir
intentar activamente que otros estados
entren o simplemente abrir la puerta
quien quiera entrar por el momento la
ota no ha obligado a ningún país miembro
a entrar en la unión de ser así Austria
o Irlanda serían miembros desde hace
muchísimos años y por si alguien se lo
está preguntando no no lo son en
realidad son los países miembros quienes
han decidido unirse y ojo porque
hablamos de gobiernos democráticos que
han solicitado su adhesión por motivos
de seguridad la otan se ha limitado a
aceptarlos en cualquier caso muchos
realistas dirían vale muy bien pero sea
como sea el hecho de que tantos países
vecinos de Rusia entren en una alianza
militar que antagoniza con Moscú por
definición es una amenaza y aquí es
donde entra el argumento que muchos
habréis oído hasta la saciedad de estos
días Estados Unidos toleraría que México
o Canadá entraran en una alianza militar
liderada por China o por Rusia y aquí es
donde entramos en condicionales Qué
pasaría si México entrara en una alianza
militar liderada por china está claro
que Washington intentaría evitarlo La
pregunta es llegarían hasta el punto de
invadirlo pues lo cierto Es que tenemos
un pequeño precedente Cuba
[Música]
como sabéis Cuba Está al lado de los
Estados Unidos durante décadas Cuba
estuvo bajo la órbita soviética incluso
llegaron a protagonizar la famosa crisis
de los misiles en el año 1962 en este
caso la unión soviética estaba colocando
misiles balísticos en Cuba se solucionó
de forma diplomática desde entonces está
claro y nadie negará que las relaciones
entre Washington y la Habana son de todo
menos amistosas pero por el momento
nunca hemos visto el ejército americano
invadir La Isla ni siquiera tras la
disolución de la unión soviética sin
embargo en el caso que nos ocupa ahora
todo empieza con este hecho la otan da
la bienvenida a las aspiraciones sobre
atlánticas de Ucrania y Georgia para su
membresía en la otan hoy Estamos de
acuerdo en que estos países llegarán a
ser miembros de la otan párrafo 23 de la
declaración de la otan en la Cumbre de
budapest de 2008 Exacto la otan habría
sus puertas a Ucrania y sí esto era una
provocación para Rusia esto nadie lo
discute La pregunta es de verdad es
razonable pensar que Ucrania iba a
unirse lo hemos tratado varias veces en
visualpolitik la respuesta es no
de entrada la mayoría de su población
estaba en contra en el año 2010 el 51%
de los ucranianos decía no a entrar en
la otan precisamente para evitar
provocar a Rusia pero no solo eso como
ya os hemos contado en varios vídeos de
visualpolitik el ejército de Ucrania no
cumplía Ninguno de los estándares de la
otan empezando porque estaba desgastado
tras años de corrupción recordad que en
el año 2014 durante la invasión de
crimea ni siquiera tenían ropa con la
que vestir a los soldados dicho de otra
forma la otan arriesgaba mucho y ganaba
muy poco y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos
si la otan no tenía claro que Ucrania
fuera entrar porque hicieron esa
declaración Por qué querían provocar a
Rusia pues pues sí este argumento es
totalmente válido y aquí el señor
mercemer tiene toda la razón de hecho la
solución que proponía para evitar la
guerra que hoy estamos viviendo es muy
realista atentos
desde luego Esta es una postura muy
legítima y es muy difícil rebatirla
sobre todo en el año en el que se hizo
esta charla el año 2015 por aquel
momento era fácil pensar que Putin se
limitaba a buscar la neutralidad de
Ucrania y nada más Incluso el propio
John mermaiger lo pensaba atentos
sin embargo la realidad ha echado por
tierra incluso las tesis más realistas
porque Putin ha hecho exactamente lo que
nadie se esperaba intentar tomar todo
Ucrania Empezando por la capital
vamos a recordar lo que ha ocurrido
desde entonces la Guerra de Ucrania
estalló en el año 2014 ese año Ucrania
no estaba pidiendo la entrada en la otan
ni muchísimo menos en realidad lo que
desató las iras de Putin fue esto
acuerdo de la asociación entre la Unión
Europea y Ucrania afirmar o no firmar
Exacto estamos hablando de un acuerdo
comercial con la Unión Europea un
acuerdo que desató unas protestas contra
el gobierno prorruso que habían kiff
muchos quieren pensar que estas
protestas fueron un golpe de estado
auspiciado por Estados Unidos pero vamos
a ser claros Ucrania ya tenía una enorme
población por europea en el año 2014 y
buena parte de esta población vivía en
la capital es decir que es bastante
realista pensar que fueron muchos de
estos ucranianos quienes conos sin ayuda
de los Estados Unidos se levantaron
contra su gobierno dicho de otra forma
que no hace falta la intervención de
Estados Unidos para explicar cualquier
fenómeno pero recordad que ni siquiera
se trataba de la entrada de Ucrania en
la Unión Europea y alguno dirá hombre
Fonseca pero firmar un acuerdo de libre
comercio con Europa implica
necesariamente entrar en la otan verdad
pues realmente no ahí tenéis El ejemplo
de Austria Irlanda Finlandia o Suecia
todos ellos Son miembros de pleno
derecho en la Unión Europea sin embargo
ninguno de estos cuatro países es
miembro de la otan y hasta este año y
Suecia ni Finlandia se planteaban entrar
dicho de otra forma que en ningún
momento estamos diciendo que Ucrania
tuviera cabezas nucleares apuntando
contra Rusia todas las hostilidades de
Rusia empezaron por un acuerdo comercial
y esperar un momento porque esta no es
la primera vez que Rusia ha tenido
conflictos con Ucrania
básicamente cada vez que los ucranianos
han elegido gobiernos que no eran
exactamente del gusto del kremlin toda
Europa ha tenido problemas con el
suministro de gas ruso que venía por el
territorio ucraniano lo vimos en el año
2005 y en el año 2008 dicho de otra
forma desatar las iras de Putin por lo
visto Es realmente fácil y ahora la
pregunta que nos deberíamos hacer es de
verdad un acuerdo de libre comercio con
Europa es semejante crisis existencial
para y la respuesta de John mercemer es
esta digamos
y la pregunta que muchos estaréis
haciendo ahora es es este un
planteamiento correcto desde luego tiene
mucho sentido ahora bien si asumimos
esto Tendremos que asumir que Ucrania no
es un estado soberano ni Ucrania ni
ningún país pequeño y ojo Esto no es
ningún argumento de hombre de paja que
me está inventando yo lo reconoce el
propio John messner atentos
[Música]
dicho de otra forma ley del más fuerte
bajo este principio Ucrania tendría que
aceptar cualquier condición de Rusia y
no solo hablamos de neutralidad militar
sino de acuerdos comerciales o incluso
de formación de gobiernos y ya sé lo que
pensaréis muchos vale es muy triste pero
el mundo funciona así Esta es la
realidad y sabéis que puede que tengáis
razón pero tener una cosa muy clara
asumir esta posición implica aceptar que
hay países destinados a ser colonias es
decir que estamos hablando de obligar a
más de 40 millones de ucranianos a no
poder elegir el partido de gobierno que
quieran o negociar Los acuerdos
comerciales que quieran o vivir bajo sus
propias condiciones como ellos quieran
Esto no es simplemente ser neutral es
aceptar no tener ningún tipo de
soberanía Y ser una colonia de Moscú no
solo eso implicaría aceptar que tampoco
podría elegir sus socios comerciales
todo para evitar desatar las iras de
Moscú y la pregunta es es realista para
Rusia pensar que Ucrania y occidente van
a aceptar estas condiciones
[Música]
en el caso de Ucrania ya hemos visto que
no son los propios ucranianos quienes
han decidido dar la batalla y ojo lo han
decidido incluso antes de contar con un
apoyo tan decidido de la otan recordad
que hasta febrero de 2022 la otan
simplemente había enviado unos pocos
lanzamisiles japelin y ni siquiera
permitían que se utilizaran en el campo
de batalla y lo que es más importante de
verdad es realista pensar a estas
alturas que Putin iba a quedarse
simplemente con Ucrania es decir porque
no iba a ir también a por otros países
que también considera una amenaza
existencial por ejemplo los bálticos
pensad que Rusia ya ha lanzado ataques a
países como Estonia incluso después de
haber entrado en la otan Ahí está sin ir
más lejos el ciber ataque del año 2007
dicho de otra forma que si el mundo es
una anarquía donde impera la ley del más
fuerte Quién es más fuerte Rusia o
Estados Unidos porque Estados Unidos y
Europa deberían plegarse a los intereses
de su antagonista cuando además es más
débil dicho esto vamos a pasar a la
siguiente teoría
[Música]
viejas muy viejas ideas
vamos a ver otra conferencia que también
se ha difundido hasta la saciedad en
este caso en el Mundo Hispano Hablamos
de una charla de José Antonio zorrilla
que es un diplomático español por
resumir su postura Estados Unidos
llevaría décadas evitando que Rusia y
Europa tengan buenas relaciones y diréis
por qué Pues atentos porque ahora sí
tenemos que ir muy atrás en el tiempo
pero muy muy muy muy atrás porque vamos
a desempolvar una de las teorías más
antiguas de la geopolítica la teoría del
pivot geográfico de la historia esta
teoría fue creada por el geógrafo Harold
mackinder en el año 1904 y dice lo
siguiente el que domina Europa del este
domina el corazón de la tierra el que
domina el corazón de la tierra dominan a
isla planeta el que domina La Isla
planeta domina el mundo tal forma kinder
Ya lo sé a muchos os acaba de estallar
la cabeza aquí qué es eso
el corazón de la tierra Pues atentos a
este mapa
lo que veis sombreado en rojo es lo que
mackinder llama el corazón de la tierra
también lo podéis encontrar en algunos
libros como el pivot geográfico según
makinder quien domina este terreno
domina la mayor parte de los recursos
naturales y las comunicaciones del
planeta eso significa que si alguien
dominara Rusia y en general Europa del
este incluyendo buena parte de Alemania
dominaría el mundo y por eso Estados
Unidos querría evitar a toda Costa una
alianza entre Alemania y Rusia el
problema El problema es que esta teoría
Podría tener cierta validez en el año
1904 hoy en día el mundo es totalmente
distinto es más de existir un pivot en
el mundo hoy en día probablemente
estaría en el sudeste asiático o en Asia
Pacífico como os podéis imaginar en la
época de maquinder Asia no tenía la
importancia que sí que tiene hoy en día
la mayor parte de los países asiáticos
por aquellos años eran colonias europeas
recursos naturales Pues si hoy en día
Tenemos que hablar de recursos naturales
Oriente medio tiene una importancia
fundamental Sin embargo a principios del
siglo el petróleo no era ni de lejos tan
importante como lo es hoy en día dicho
de otra forma que las teorías de
makinder hoy en día están totalmente
superadas pero hablando de teorías
superadas hay muchos que aseguran que
Ucrania También estaría desempolvando
otras teorías que parecían haberse
pasado de moda para siempre sí ahora es
cuando vamos a responder a la pregunta
que muchos nos habéis hecho en los
comentarios mil y una veces atentos
[Música]
es Ucrania un país nazi
lo habéis oído hasta la saciedad porque
la propaganda rusa no se cansa en
repetir que quieren desnatificar Ucrania
y lo cierto Es que no solo son los
propagandistas rusos muchos
intelectuales en occidente están
convencidos de que Putin tiene su parte
de razón atentos la República
independiente de Ucrania se constituye
bajo la protección del Tercer raíz sobre
esta gente se quería edificar la nueva
Ucrania los resultados todavía los
tenemos a este señor es un embajador
español en principio no tienen nada que
ver con los protagonistas rusos y lo
cierto es que tiene razón de hecho si
veis algunos discursos de Putin veréis
que hace alusión a los supuestos
banderistas y diréis quiénes son los
banderistas Pues bien estos son los
seguidores de Stefan bandera uno de los
padres del nacionalismo ucraniano
Durante los años 40 estepan bandera
colaboró con los nazis en la invasión de
Ucrania este hombre fue responsable de
limpiezas étnicas y toda clase de
violaciones contra los Derechos Humanos
sin embargo muchos ucranianos Incluso
hoy en día le consideran Un héroe
nacional de hecho recibió el título
póstumo de héroe de Ucrania en el año
2010 curiosamente Este título se lo dio
el presidente prorruso Víctor yanuko
ahora está apoyado por Putin pero eso es
otra historia
por suerte o por desgracia la historia
está llena de personajes así y muchos de
ellos son elevados a los altares por eso
de que el enemigo de mi enemigo es mi
amigo dicho de otra forma en el momento
más duro de las purgas de stalin con las
hambrunas provocadas por Rusia para
castigar a Ucrania y el famoso olodomor
muchos ucranianos como os podéis
imaginar se echaron en brazos de los
alemanes pero no solo los ucranianos
también Finlandia se alió con el tercer
right durante su guerra contra Rusia
Suecia que en principio se mantuvo
neutral durante toda la Segunda Guerra
Mundial permitió que los alemanes
cruzaran su territorio e incluso
colaboraron En algunos momentos con el
ejército nazi significa esto que Suecia
o Finlandia sean países nazis hoy en día
obviamente no y más en el caso de
Ucrania si estudiáis su historia durante
todo el siglo XX entenderéis que han
tenido todo tipo de alianzas y casi
todas han salido mal
en cualquier caso las figuras políticas
cambian y se resignifican y si no que se
lo pregunten a los venezolanos Sí sí la
figura de Simón Bolívar se ha ensalzado
como un héroe del llamado socialismo del
Siglo 21 sin embargo Simón Bolívar fue
un burgués en la época que fue criticado
incluso por el propio Marx sin embargo
la realidad hoy en día es que a
diferencia de otros países como por
ejemplo Grecia Ucrania no tiene a ningún
partido de nazi en su parlamento ninguno
no hay representación nazi en el
parlamento ucraniano ahora bien como os
podéis imaginar en un país de más de 40
millones de habitantes hay grupos con
ideologías de todo tipo y sí es cierto
existen batallones dentro del ejército
ucraniano que sí tienen ideología
neonazi La pregunta es de verdad alguien
Espera que en mitad de una invasión el
ejército rechace unos soldados solo por
ideología
[Música]
hombre creo que todos entendemos que
Ucrania en estos momentos está dispuesta
a reclutar a cualquiera que quiera ir al
frente a luchar utilizar esto como
argumento para demostrar que todo el
país de más de 40 millones de habitantes
está bajo un régimen nazi Lo siento
mucho es vivir en un Mundo paralelo y
llegados a este punto turno para el
debate Hasta qué punto creéis que la
otan o Estados Unidos o incluso la Unión
Europea deben comprometerse con ucranias
deberían seguir enviando armamento que
gana Estados Unidos o la otan
debilitando a Rusia podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
por favor demostrado una vez más que la
comunidad de visualpolitik es la más
respetuosa y la más civilizada de todas
Así que discutir con respeto y con
argumentos Y como siempre recordad que
aquí seguimos sacando vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]